[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dis moi tu te sens au milieu de la rue
rien ne va toucher ton coeur témoin tout
ça fait trop mal on doit tellement déçu
que tu te vois mal c'est normal tu sais
dans la vie on sait tous plantes
c
comme une forme du sud
personne n'est parfait
on est tous sortis du jeu
tu sais dans la mire
ça
[Musique]
ça va ça vient
dis-le moi
ça fait
[Musique]
dis-moi dis-moi si plus rien n'a de sens
itil
plus la fois plus rien à donner
dieu moi
c'est à tout au long de change qui
craque
c
voire même réseau
personne n'est pas
sortie toujours
je fais dans la vie
ça va ça vient
bien
tu veux
[Musique]
ça va
ça
en panne
ils sont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
si c'est dans la vie ça va ça va
ça
[Musique]
dumas
ça
un ça va
[Musique]
oh
on est con
qui sont mes biens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]